♪ ♪
>> Laura: , PLAYING LIMITS FOR
FOOLS THAT'S TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS LACING
AMERICA WITH MISERY AS FAR AS
THE EYE CAN SEE.
AMERICANS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS ARE
LOOKING ACROSS A DISMAL ECONOMIC
LANDSCAPE.
THE SIGNS OF DESPAIR YOU SEE
THEM, I SEE THEM THERE BUILDING.
AND THE FURY IS GROWING TOWARDS
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IT IS
ASTOUNDING.
I LOVE DROWNING YOU ALL THE
NUMBERS I HATE THAT.
FROM AND TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION
TONIGHT BECAUSE IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT DISAPPROVAL FOR THE
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY.
MY QUESTION IS OR WHO ARE THESE
34% WHO APPROVE OF HIM?
THE ANSWERS FOR MIDDLE-CLASS
ONLY 36% SAY THAT HE'S HELPING
WITH THE MIDDLE CLASS THAT'S
DOWN FROM A WHOLE 5% FROM
FEBRUARY, AND AMERICANS SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING I THINK IT,
LOOK AT THIS THEY'RE GETTING
POOR AS DAYS GO ON.
THERE WERE MEMBER HOW THE
DIMWITTED TREASURY I MEMBER WHEN
SHE JUST BRUSHED OFF INFLATION
CONCERNS A YEAR AGO WE MADE A
BIG DEAL OF AND
TODAY WE SAW A HISTORIC RATE
HIKE A DESPERATE MOVE WITH
TERRIBLE CONSEQUENCES FOR
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
>> IT'LL BE MORE EXPENSIVE TO
BORROW MONEY, IF IT TRY TO BUY A
HOME, EXPERTS SAY THAT THE
ASKING PRICE MAY NOT BE MUCH
HIGHER THAN IT IS NOW, BUT THE
COST TO BUY THAT HOUSE IS GONNA
BE HIGHER.
>> BECAUSE MORTGAGE RATES ARE
GOING UP.
>> THAT MEANS MANY HOMEOWNERS
WILL ONLY BE PAYING HIGHER
INTEREST ON THEIR MORTGAGE, BUT
THAT ALSO GET LESS HOUSE FOR
THEIR MONEY.
>> Laura: AND IF YOU BUILT UP
SOME CREDIT CARD DEBTS OF THE
PAST YEAR.
>> IF YOU HAVE CREDIT CARD DEBT
IT'S IN COST YOU MORE.
IF YOU BUY A CAR CAN COST YOU
MORE.
BECAUSE THE RATES TO BORROW THAT
MONEY TO GET THAT CAR IS IN GO
UP.
>> Laura: AND JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO YOU ALL REMEMBER THIS UNDER
DONALD TRUMP ECONOMIC OPTIMISM
IS LOOKING BACK IN NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER OF 2019, YOUNG
AMERICANS OF MINORITIES, OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS HAD RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE RISING WAGES, NO INFLATION,
NO NEW WARS, CHEAP GAS, AND NOW
EVERYTHING IS GOING THE WRONG
WRONG DIRECTION.
ON THAT EVERYONE IS BEING
TOLD OH, JUST LOWER YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
>> CAN WHAT MANY OF US DO WITH
THESE HIGHER INTEREST RATES THAT
ARE COMING?
THE ANALYST SAID THAT IF YOU CAN
HOLD OFF ON THAT MAJOR PURCHASE
OF A HOUSE, OR CAR THAT HUMAN
THING ABOUT, HOLD THAT OFFER AS
LONG AS YOU CAN.
WITH SOME SAYING THAT IT'S TIME
TO THINK OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
REGARDING YOUR LIVING SITUATION.
THAT WOULD HAVE RELATIVES OR
SHARING A ANYBODY ELSE, THAT CAN
HELP YOU WRITE OUT SOME OF THESE
RATE HEIGHTS.
>> Laura: YEAH YOU WANT TO GO
BACK, LIVED WITH MOMMY AND DADDY
RIGHT?
THIS ENTIRE GRIM ENVIRONMENT
WITH THE MIDTERM WIPEOUT LOOMING
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, THERE JUST
LEFT TO KATA ROLE FROM STAGE
LEFT, FEARMONGERING AND LYING
ABOUT THE COURT'S DECISION TO
OVERTURN ROE V. WADE LIKE THEY
DID WITH COVID.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE THAT THIS IS
ABOUT CONTROLLING WOMEN, FAR
RIGHT POLITICIANS ARE WORKING TO
RESTRICT ALL FAMILY-PLANNING
SERVICES, DENYING A WHOLE
GENERATION OF WOMEN THE FREEDOM
TO PLAN FOR THEIR FUTURE.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE NO ANSWERS
ON NEW MEXICO'S INFLATION, THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION ISSUE THAT'S
PLAGUING THE STATES, BUT SHE
DOES HAVE TALKING POINTS FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
THE ISSUE IS JUST RETURNED TO
THE STATES, SHE DOES UNDERSTAND
HOW TO READ A LEGAL DRAFT,
SECOND THE CONGRESSWOMAN,
SENATOR THINKS SO LITTLE OF
WOMAN'S INTELLIGENCE THAT SHE
BELIEVES WOMEN CAN ONLY PLANNED
PREGNANCIES BY ABORTING THEIR
OFFSPRING.
HOW INSULTING.
IN ANOTHER EFFORT TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT CAME FOR THE WOMEN WHO
IS A HEARTBEAT AWAY FROM THE
PRESIDENCY YET PRETENSE THAT
LIBERATION IS FOUND IN STOPPING
THE HEARTBEATS OF THE UNBORN.
>> THOSE ARE PUBLIC AND LEADERS
WHO ARE TRYING TO WEAPONIZE THE
USE OF THE LAW AGAINST WOMEN.
WHAT WE SAY HOW DARE THEY.
HOW DO THEY TELL A WOMAN WHAT
SHE CAN DO AND CANNOT DO WITH
HER OWN BODY.
HOW DARE THEY.
TRY TO DENY WOMEN THERE RIGHT
AND THEIR FREEDOM.
>> SHE JUST HOPES OF THE
PROMPTER DOES GO DOWN.
JUST ANOTHER DEMOCRAT THAT
DOESN'T TRUST THE VOTERS TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES.
SHE'D RATHER HAVE NINE UNELECTED
JUSTICES MAKE THAT DECISION
WELL, UNTIL LEASE THE RULING
WITH THE OTHER WAY.
THEN SHE IS LEFT SPUTTERING
ABOUT PLATITUDES ABOUT BODILY
AUTONOMY AFTER HER AND HER PARTY
STILL TRIED TO FORCE VACCINES ON
WOMEN WHO DIDN'T WANT THEM.
NONE OF THIS BY THE WAY HIS
PRINCIPAL.
BUT SHE IS SO APOPLECTIC ABOUT
THE G.O.P.'S TSUNAMI THAT'S
ABOUT TO SWAMP THEM SHE'S EVEN
TRYING TO CONVINCE YOU THAT THE
MOVEMENT THAT RESULTED IN
50 MILLION BABIES BEING ABORTED
IS PATRIOTIC.
>> IF YOU STAND FOR FREEDOM AND
SELF-DETERMINATION.
FOR THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY IF YOU
STAND TO THESE PRINCIPLES STAND
WITH US.
[APPLAUSE]
BECAUSE WOMAN'S ISSUES ARE
AMERICA'S ISSUES.
LET US FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
FOR THE PRINCIPLES UPON WHICH IT
WAS FOUNDED AND LET US FIGHT
WITH EVERYTHING WE HAVE GOT,
GOD BLESS YOU AND GOD BLESS
AMERICA.
>> Laura: NOW THE PRINCIPLE
THAT THE COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED
INCLUDING ABORTING CHILDREN.
NO ONE BELIEVES THAT.
A PSYCHO WORK.
NOW BACK IN THE 70s-80s AND
EVEN INTO THE 90s.
MANY LIBERALS SUPPORT ABORTION
FOR SURE.
BUT NOW LIBERALISM IS DEFINED BY
ABORTION.
THERE ARE NO REAL PRO-LIFE
DEMOCRATS LIKE FINDING ONE
DIFFERENT GROUP.
THEIR BOATSWAIN 2022 HAS ZERO
HESITATION ABOUT THINGS LIKE
SELLING OUT TO CHINA,
DICTATORSHIP THAT BRUTALIZED
WOMEN WHO ARE CHRISTIANS ARE
GORGEOUS WOMEN WHO WANT TO HAVE
A BIG FAMILY.
THEIR BOATSWAIN 2022 THEY LINE
UP WITH THE MILITARY INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX WITH WANTS A WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
LABELS IN 2022 SUPPORT
RESTRICTIONS ON MOVEMENT, CITING
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH IS WHY THEY
LOVE THE LOCKDOWN.
LIBERALS IN 2022 SUPPORT
RESTRICTIONS ON SPEECH UNDER THE
BOGUS RATIONALE OF
DISINFORMATION.
IN THE SAME LIBERALS WHO USED TO
BE ABOUT TOLERANCE NOW SITE HATE
SPEECH TO BAR PEOPLE FROM
SPEAKING IN PUBLIC TO BE A PART
OF PUBLIC LIFE.
OF COURSE THEIR DEFINITION OF
HATE SPEECH A PURPOSELY VAGUE IT
SO IS CHANGING.
SUFFICE OF TO SAY THAT LIBERALS
WHO SAY THINGS THAT DENIGRATE
ENTIRE GROUPS OF AMERICANS BASED
ON POLITICAL AFFILIATION ARE
NEVER GUILTY OF HATE SPEECH.
THEY'VE EVOLVED AND CHANGED AND
GONE 180 ON SO MANY ISSUES BUT
NOT ON THIS ONE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH FETAL
MEDICINE HAS IMPROVED HER
ANTIGEN.
FOR THE WIDE ARRAY OF BIRTH
CONTROL THAT'S AVAILABLE.
THE NUMBER OF COUPLES DESPERATE
TO ADOPT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME ABORTION
FANATICS.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
AMONG A HANDFUL OF ISSUES THAT
MAKE UP THEIR HOLY GRAIL OF
ISSUES.
IT'S A DREARY DARK WORLD THAT
THEY'RE CREATING.
AND ONE WERE WOMEN ARE THE ONES
WHO REALLY END UP SUFFERING THE
MOST.
THE LESS ANSWERED EVERYTHING IS
IT'S KIND OF SUMMED UP BY MORE
HOT, MORE, MORE ABORTION, MORE
SEXUAL IDENTITY AND
INDOCTRINATION AND RACIALIST
TERMINATION.
MORE AMERICAN TRADITION TRASHED,
MORE STATUES SMASHED.
THEIR IDEA OF EMPOWERMENT
EXCLUDES LOVELY ACTIVITIES LIKE
SLOT WALKS.
>> Laura: RECENTLY ARGUED THAT
WOMEN'S HAVE THE HAPPINESS MEANS
SHRUGGING OFF PRUDENCE AND
PROBABLY EMBRACING PREMATURITY.
BUT I THINK WOMEN ARE ON TO THIS
GAME.
AND ONTO THE GAME WITH THE
DEMOCRATS OF THEM PLAYING FOR A
WHILE NOW.
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THAT THEY KNOW
THAT LIFE IS GETTING HARDER FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEY KNOW WHO'S RESPONSIBLE.
THEY'RE SMART.
AND